Speaker 1: We have another one of these completely
Kafkaesque moments in American politics.
Donald Trump has endorsed Eric in a missouri
Republican Senate primary.
Both of the top candidates are named Eric,
and both Eric are taking credit.
Saying I have been endorsed by Donald Trump.
It is an absolutely bizarre, bizarre situation.
And Donald Trump, again, as The Daily Beast
reports, throwing the race into chaos with
his Eric endorsement.
Check this out, Donald.
There were questions about whether Donald
Trump would or would not endorse anyone in
this race.
One of the Eric Eric Greitens was very much
lobbying for the Trump endorsement.
He's done some wacky things, including bizarre
campaign ads and so many different things.
The primary is today and last night.
Donald Trump puts out the following endorsement.
There is a big election in the great state
of Missouri, by the way.
Half the words are capitalized.
Just I'm not even going to mention that as
we go, because just half of the words are
randomly capitalized.
Okay.
There is a big election in the great state
of Missouri, and we must send a MAGA champion
and true warrior to the U.S. Senate, someone
who will fight for border security, election
integrity, our military and great veterans,
together with having a powerful toughness
on crime and the border.
We need a person who will not back down to
the radical left lunatics who are destroying
our country.
I trust the great people of Missouri on this
one to make up their own minds, much as they
did when they gave me landslide victories
in the 2016 and 2020 elections.
And I am therefore proud to announce that
Erick all caps.
Erick has my complete and total endorsement.
This is another unbelievable Kafkaesque fiasco.
Both candidates are named Eric.
He doesn't say which Eric he's endorsing,
clearly trying to have it both ways.
No matter which Eric wins, Trump can claim
victory.
And the under girding of this is that MAGA
world.
The maggots are sort of divided on the race.
Some of them like Eric Greitens, some of them
like Eric Schmidt, some of them don't know
what's up and what's down and day and night.
And they're just in a fog and have absolutely
no idea what's going on whatsoever.
Now, earlier on, there were some anecdotal
reports that Trump was planning on or intended
to endorse Eric Greitens, but it genuinely
doesn't appear that that's the case.
Now, check this out.
Both of them, both Eric's accepting the endorsement.
Eric Greitens immediately posting, honored
to have the support of president trump.
We will maga with this big picture that says
president trump endorses eric greitens.
Greitens also tweeting, quote, I am honored
to receive Trump's endorsement.
From the beginning, I've been the true MAGA
champion fighting against the rhino establishment
backing Schmidt.
President Trump said it best when he characterized
Schmidt's campaign as great dishonesty in
politics.
Well, I guess then Trump endorsed Greitens,
right?
Well, no, not really.
Schmidt also took credit for the endorsement,
going to Twitter with red alarm emojis saying
endorsement.
President Trump I'm grateful for President
Trump's endorsement as the only America first
candidate who has actually fought for election
integrity, border security, and against the
left's indoctrination of our kids.
I'll take that fight to the Senate to save
America.
They both sound like unhinged MAGA lunatics,
using all of the hallmarks of of that random
capitalization of non proper nouns in their
tweets, delusions of grandeur and general
confusion about how American politics works.
They both sort of sound like pretty good MAGA
candidates.
So Donald Trump, it's really a cop out.
Initially, it seemed like Trump was just confused,
like Trump intended to endorse one or the
other Eric and ended up accidentally not.
It now is looking abundantly clear that this
is just another Trump copout and he'll call
this a victory no matter what, whichever of
the Erich's ends up winning.
Trump's going to say, I got another one.
Put another slash mark in my win column.